[Music]
Mexico has got to help us at the border
if they're not going to help us at the
border it's a very sad thing we do cut
Mexico has got to help us at the border
and a lot of people are coming in
because they want to take advantage of
daca but Mexico has got to help us at
the border they flow right through
Mexico they say the United States
welcome back to this special edition of
Hannity America's illegal immigration
crisis President Trump is publicly
calling up Mexico and pushing its
government to do its part and help
secure the border between our two
countries
this comes as migrants from Central
America are flowing through Mexico into
the United States just how bad is the
situation on our southern border joining
us now is the president of the National
Border Patrol Council and 20-year Border
Patrol veteran Brandon Judd and former
sheriff from Pinal County Arizona
Arizona is my home state Paul Babeu
thank you gentlemen so much for being
here tonight
Brandon I'll start with you your
reaction to the president calling on
Mexico to do more he did the absolute
right thing when you look at it Mexico
is actually facilitating the government
of Mexico is actually facilitating these
individuals to come up to our borders
and break US law or the sovereignty of
the United States he should absolutely
call on the leaders of the Mexican
government to put an end to this they
have very strict immigration laws yet
they're throwing their laws over their
shoulder to allow these people to come
up and break our laws that cannot happen
Sheriff Pat view I want to talk to you
about the local law enforcement
perspective of this you were in charge
of a County Pinal County which is not a
border county but it's an a border state
has border county problems so talk about
how when Mexico allows thousands of
people to come through into the United
States without stopping them or vetting
them how that affects deputies on the
ground
well crime one you're adding criminal
illegals besides it's not just the
millions and millions of illegals who
are here many of them are as president
Trump has pointed out have criminal
records in their home countries
nevermind here and it's as figures as
high as 30 percent of these millions and
millions so there's a cost of that not
just in terms of incarceration and law
enforcement but also with education and
medical care it's estimated just for the
state of Arizona your home state which
we're very proud of you
is close to two billion dollars every
year so this is an extreme cost not just
in terms of the social and the law
enforcement aspect but in terms of
actual dollars and cents so what's
different here is that these aren't just
illegals being escorted by coyotes or
guides this is an actual almost like as
Brandon pointed out sanctioned by the
government of Mexico 1,200 potentially
marching towards the border and even
though that may sound like a small
number how we deal with this sends a
message to Mexico to Central America
because if we accept them as refugees or
asylum seekers we're going to see tens
and tens of thousands right replicating
this president Trump took a little bit
of heat today Brandon for first saying
and arguing that these illegal aliens
are coming to United States to take
advantage of daca well he should have
said as they're coming to take advantage
of any kind of amnesty that gets put on
the table for people who get their feet
on the ground here we saw this in 2014
with the child immigration unaccompanied
minor crisis when people just sent their
kids up and knew that if they could go
there and stay there they get sent to a
family member in the United States and
would never be sent back so talk about
the fact that when anyone in Washington
starts talking about some kind of
amnesty whether it's daca the dreamer
program anything citizenship we see an
increase of unaccompanied minors illegal
aliens coming across the border and
specifically in the last couple of
months family units making it across
hoping they get to stay all you have to
do is go down and speak with the
individuals that are impacted the
ranchers I was out on a tour of the
border with Senator Cornyn Senate
senator Heller and a couple other
senators a couple months ago and we were
at a ranch estate and the owners of the
estates specifically said every
single time we start talking about
immigration reform or an amnesty we see
hundreds of people come across our ranch
they find dead bodies on their ranch all
the time and and the increase is always
when we start talking about an amnesty
program we cannot talk about any sort of
amnesty whether that's daca or
comprehensive immigration reform unless
we secure the border first once we
secure the border then we can start
talking about things so that we don't
put ourselves in this same situation
five ten years from now
erricka of 1986 was supposed to fix that
problem right and it didn't because they
put the cart before the horse they they
legalized everybody but they didn't put
the border security measures in place we
have to put the border security measures
in place first right the White House has
made it very clear they want to solve
this problem once and for all they don't
want to have to be dealing with it later
on but sure if I want to talk to you
about the human aspect of this because
yes people who stand up for border
security are accused of being inhumane
they're accused of being racist they're
accused of not being empathetic to those
who are fleeing violent situations but
what about the journey here I've always
said that open borders are inhumane
borders I'm sure that you've seen some
terrible things as a result of people
being told by these coyotes we'll take
care of you we'll take you through the
desert we'll make sure it happens just
fine and it actually turns out to be a
horrific experience for these people it
is their their victimized not only it's
brutal because of the barren deserts and
they're walking days upon days many of
them died hundreds each year it's
estimated and they're victimized as well
not only there you're spending their
life savings giving it to these escorts
these coyotes they're robbing them
they're raping them we've had countless
cases in my eight years as sheriff where
they've been raped multiple times these
are juveniles and so in to your point
about us and what some liberals say
we're not compassionate or we're not
being true to our proud history as a
land of immigrants completely false we
are the most compassionate most generous
nation still to this day nearly 1
million
illegal immigrants each and every year
that we allow in far in excess of any
other nations so we're proud of that but
we can't just have open borders and
whoever wants to get to the border
you're home free
those were the Obama days and we're done
with those yeah
Brandon sheriff we're out of time
unfortunately but thank you so much for
bringing your on the ground perspective
to the show we really appreciate it